President Biden accused of going hyper
partisan in a speech where he was going
to be honoring the life of Dr Martin
Luther King Jr the president who
preaches Unity using the occasion to
attack his Republican critics
you know they're talking you're going to
talk about big spending Democrats again
guess what
I reduced the deficit last year
350 billion dollars but so what these
guys are the fiscally you know the
fiscally demented I think they don't
I don't quite get it Florida Congressman
Byron Donalds responded to being called
fiscally demented Joe Biden sounds
utterly ridiculous what he wants to do
is keep all of the the items that he has
ratcheted up spending in he wants to
keep those in place as opposed to doing
the smart thing the responsible thing
the fiscally sound thing which is
examining spending at the federal level
so we can get our debt under control our
inflation under control and the
president turning some heads with these
comments about the Second Amendment and
car insurance
I am going to get assault weapons banned
I did it once I'm going to do it again I
love my right-wing friends to talk about
the tree of Liberty is whatever the
blood of patriots
give me if you need to work about taking
on the federal government you need some
f-15s you don't need an RAR 15. I'm
serious and by the way if you're live in
one of those neighborhoods and you have
the same exact car I have in the other
neighborhood you pay more for your
insurance in that size no basis for it
none at all other than you're black ah
and I'm white oh my Unity Greg yeah you
know I don't want I I swore like when he
became president that I we wouldn't be
like them like the trumped Arrangement
syndrome but Biden uh I refused to see
him as evil uh or inherently bad but he
is pathetic uh in the sense that he was
always kind of uh known for being
um
have manners and have class and
congenial but here there's a tribute to
MLK and he uses it to demonize a party
and so you start thinking well what what
is this is this the Joe Biden that
everybody thought they knew of course
not that one is dead I mean this isn't
even a thinking self-aware individual at
this point he's Joy Reed with an
artificial hip he will say anything or
do anything he doesn't care but I got to
go back to that line that he always uses
it's so tired about the F-15 you know it
when he says you know you can't fight
the government unless you have an F-15
he's like that obnoxious stupid child at
a zoo banging on the window of a lion
enclosure and saying ahaha you can't get
me you can't get me that is literally
the level of his infantile discourse
he's trying he's basically trying to
goad people into his civil confrontation
after claim gaming after claiming that q
a q Anon Shaman threatened our democracy
so you can't have it both ways you dope
brain you can't say that our democracy
is in Peril because of a Motley bunch of
rioters and then say hey good luck
overthrowing the government with your
AR-15s he's absolutely lost his mind and
again I'm not losing my mind over this
this is not derangement syndrome this is
simply watching the the decline of an
individual and you can say this you can
say that he's lost his mind now because
there's nothing worse than somebody
calling you a racist in this Society so
that he's he has extended that that
platform that bar so that when you say
that he's senile or just idiotic that's
nothing close to being called a racist
because being being demented is out of
your control but when somebody calls you
a racist that is a an attack on your
moral being so I guess all bets are off
at this point
um when I wanted everybody to know you
have to stick around for my one more
thing because there's a deep tease you
don't even know what it is but you just
deep tease my wife I hope it doesn't
involve kill meat no it might involve it
I'm gonna be on the whole show
I want to play if you could play the
call for about the IRS and we'll get
Judge Jeanine to respond here watch this
you know all these new IRS agents we
have is because they fired a lot of them
and a lot of retiring and guess what
who needs serious agents to know what
they're doing or not doing
the billionaires the
multi-multi-millionaires this one bill
alone will add
114 billion dollars to the deficit they
didn't say if elected their plan was to
make inflation worse
judge the reason they needed the 87 000
IRS agents is so that they could make
the math work to get the infrastructure
Bill done so that Mansion wouldn't vote
against it it all goes to Green
subsidies that's why they got the agents
thank you for explaining that because
nothing he said made sense but I have to
tell you I have four things I want to
comment down from the speech number one
I think he's one of the most divisive
presidents in American history this is a
president who has taken on the American
people as opposed to taking on people in
a foreign country who want you know
Americans to die in Israel to die and
all that stuff number two
um he's he is someone who is taking all
this credit and calling us crazy about
the economy when the truth is he ran the
deficit up to a world record of 2.5
trillion in 2021 and then in 2022
borrowed another 1.5 trillion which is
also the highest ever so he's the most
financially Reckless president that
we've ever had and you know it's like an
alcoholic bragging look I went from
eight drinks to six drinks I'm you know
things are really good now then the
other thing this comment about you know
they should be able to shoot them in the
leg they shouldn't be able to shoot them
look cops are trained to shoot Center
Mass when they are when they are
resisting deadly physical Force it's not
like a western where you got some guy
who's going to shoot that gun out of
your hand okay unless you've got a
sniper you go for Center Mass that's
another thing that shows he's totally
disconnected and finally this idea of um
uh the Illinois governor and the assault
weapons and all that first of all the
the assault weapon ban in 93 the results
of it are very unclear very unclear and
he says he wants to do it again fine and
the Illinois governor is telling his
sheriffs they won't have their job if
they don't enforce the assault weapon
ban in Illinois he can't take their jobs
away from them because they've been
elected right that's it Geraldo doesn't
President Biden have to make a decision
if he's going to announce to he's
running for re-election
is he going to be the congenial unifying
president that he said that he would be
that you don't have to worry about
anything or the divisive one that seems
to be where he defaults to in these
speeches you're much more of an expert
on politics than I am on this one I
don't know well I I was just going to
say that uh it was like a stoner stream
of Consciousness that speech it was one
of the most disconnected really and I I
like the guy I just didn't know where he
was going uh with the you know like the
AR-15s what does that have to do with
the the 87 000 IRS agents and it just
seemed the whole mishmash and it also
seemed ominously to speak of the
division that you mentioned judge you
know uh does he want two sides to uh but
let me let me if I may say as a with
considerable experience in War uh I just
wanted to give you a quick picture again
30 seconds Moga issue Somalia I was
there in 2002 with my brother Craig and
we watched a young doctor bleed out he
died right in front of us his head had
been blown up blown off or half of it
taken away by an AR-15
I
submit to you ladies and gentlemen there
is no legitimate reason other than maybe
sport shooting if you're a registered uh
person in one of those high-end sport
clubs
there's no legitimate reason to have an
AR-15 you can't shoot deer with it you
can't it has no practical significance
what it does is it it matchifies if
that's a word it it makes makes Macho
the people who possess it oh look at me
I'm a big deal and it's it's not a right
yes it's a rifle it is it is it is
no no that's not what it is well I all I
know is that AR-15s have no place in
American society other than sport clubs
and I agree with them on that I also
think ironically that we do need uh more
IRS agents if they say we need more IRS
agents
um he Brian he took takes credit for
reducing the deficit but that was after
the covid emergency funds went down
right and so it's like when he says it's
the greatest airlift in history yeah or
when the and including on baby formula
it's like they're he's
writing checks he can't cash so to speak
it's it's if he doesn't get briefed on
things he gets wrong it's the same
stories over and over again the Mandela
story he got arrested outside the prison
no one ever says him don't say that
anymore the train story no one ever says
hey by the way that's not true don't say
it anymore the uh the F-15 he says that
over and over again the analogy is done
have you talked to a cop they never say
shoot for the leg everybody knows it's a
chewed for the mess know what you don't
know and when it comes to spending he
spent 9.7 trillion dollars and we know
that this is going to be over the next
10 years four point uh is going to spend
uh six trillion dollars over the next 10
years so this is all coming down the
pike he wants to reduce spending the
thing is he's fortuitous in this Mitch
McConnell came across on the uh on the
deal when it comes to the infrastructure
he came across the aisle when it came to
the chips bill was originally a
Republican bill he's taking credit for
these bills that the Senate actually
kind of deal with which mostly
Republicans had agreed with and he just
signs it in fact he almost blew it up
because he says I will not sign one
without the other so to me the scariest
thing for his staff if they are paying
attention is when he walks around
clearly not looking at the prompter
because you have no idea what's going to
happen and believe me he does not want
to use the word demented it was one of
the worst words
yeah I wouldn't use that word can I say
one thing yes of course uh there's no
social redeeming value uh to an assault
weapon the Constitution doesn't limit
something to a socially redeeming uh
Factor there were no assault weapons oh
should we have cannons in our house
let's not go there yeah I guess it's
just a quick thing we only have six what
does AR stand for anyway
um you should look it up
take kill me devices not counting right
not counting breaks not assault we have
607 billion uh 607 billionaires in this
country not counting Greg 606. so that's
who we're cracking down on the
billionaires who have the best best
accountants most of them are just
playing within the system 87
000 agents are going after your small
business there's more questions
absolutely right I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now